it is almost the end of the winter and
you've woken up to a cold house which is
weird because you left the heater on all
night you turn on the lights
it's not working actually the
coffeemaker the TV none of them are
working life outside also seems to have
stops there are no schools most of the
businesses are shocked and don't know
working trains this is not the opening
scene of a zombie apocalypse movie this
is what happens in March 1989 in the
Canadian province of Quebec when the
para greats lost power the culprits a
solar storm solar storms a giant class
of particles escaping from the Sun from
time to time and a constant reminder
that we'll live in the neighborhood of
an active star an i as a solar physicist
I have a tremendous chance to study
these stellar stones but you see Salah
stone chaser is not just a cool title
marry such helps to understand where
they come from how they behave and in
the long run aims to mitigate the
effects on human societies which I'll
get to in a second at the beginning of
the space exploration age fifty years
ago only the probes with sentence in
space revealed that the planets in our
solar system constantly bathed in a
stream of particles that are coming from
the Sun and that we call the solar wind
and in the same way that global wind
patterns here on earth can be affected
by hurricanes the solar winds is
sometimes affected by solar stones that
electrical space hurricanes when they
arrive at planets they can perturb the
space environment which in turns create
Northern or thousand lights for example
here on earth but also
and also Jupiter luckily here on earth
we are protected by our planets natural
shield a magnetic bubble that we call
the magnetosphere and that you can see
here on the right side nonetheless solar
storms can still responsible for
disrupting satellite telecommunications
and operations for disrupting navigation
systems such as the GPS as well as
electric power transmission all of these
or technologies on which us humans rely
more and more I mean imagine if you work
up tomorrow without a working cell phone
no internet on it which means no social
media I mean to me that would be worse
than the zombie apocalypse by constantly
monitoring the Sun though we now know
where the solar storms come from they
come from regions of the Sun where a
tremendous amount of energy is being
stored you have an example here as a
complex structure hanging above the
solar surface just on the verge of
erupting unfortunately we cannot send
probes in the scorching hot atmosphere
of the Sun where temperatures can rise
up to around 10 million degrees Kelvin
so what I do is that I use computer
simulations in order to analyze but also
to predict the behavior of the storms
when they are just born at the Sun this
is only one part of the story though
when the solar storms are moving in
space
some of them will inevitably encounter
space probes that we humans have sent in
order to explore other worlds what I
mean by other worlds is for example
planets such as Venus or mercury but
also objects should such as comets and
while the space probes have been made
for different scientific endeavors they
can also act like tiny cosmic
meteorological station and monitor
devilish
nobody's space thumbs so I with a group
of researchers gather and analyze this
data coming from different locations of
the solar system and by doing so my
research shows that actually solar
storms have a generic shape and that is
shape evolves as Scylla stones move away
from the Sun and you know what this is
key for building tools to predict space
weather I would like to leave you with
this beautiful image this is us here on
earth this pale blue dot and while I
study the Sun and it's stones every day
and will always have a deep love for
this beautiful planet a pale blue dot
indeed but a pale blue dot with an
invisible magnetic shield that helps to
protect us thank you
[Applause]